she's just what's called a supermodel
and from another country yeah yeah her
man's bradley
well there are women who are russian
ukrainian polish who are
impossibly hot and they have their phds
so that is phd no but but for the story
in my fantasy she has a phd does she
she's a scientist she's a scientist
you're in the lab coat she's in a laptop
capcom tits
no she she has demure perfect tits
they're not like she's she's so hot if
she was in a lab coat and like she
leaked the covet virus i'd like come on
i would never put her in jail right hey
hey she made a mistake irina
shake
uh she where is she from czech republic
or something or serbia croatia some
someplace like that says she's from
heaven she's from heaven she's from
heaven she's sometimes you sometimes in
the womb
everything works together and there's a
symmetry that happens there's a symmetry
and and and a length of bone and and all
that stuff where everything goes perfect
and and there you are yeah she's wrong
she's russian yeah
she's from the
cela binsk oblask region
um her dad is a coal miner
mama was a kindergarten teacher so she
comes from humble [ __ ] roots yeah her
she grew up broke yeah broke his [ __ ]
actress
i mean a model and probably for real
most of them have like four degrees
yeah i don't know if she does but you
know i like it i mean that's almost like
a story but you like that that's a story
again she could leak the virus and be
fine with it if she was the cause of the
virus
and people were bullying her online i
would come to her defense
i'd get monkey box for her yeah and i
would never arrest her if there was like
a terrible murder oh no no i don't come
in what the hell she's sitting there
with two knives like
yeah i go like this i go give me the
knife come on let's get you cleaned up
i'd be wearing free irania shirts and
[ __ ] yeah
arena arena yeah
i like irania
oh irina don't say irina because that's
shock yeah
yeah you don't pull bradley cooper by
looking like a troll no
we had some fun time in austin huh buddy
we had a great time
brenton and i were given the tour of
joe's new studio and both of us started
laughing and he looked at me and we knew
exactly what we were thinking because
that's how well we know each other and i
just looked at him and i went i'm a
failure and he goes know me too failures
i was going well no think boys kind of
like this but a little different i think
about the same dude i mean he has a
straight up 24-hour fitness it's this
thick boy is the room you keep your
deprivation tank in no think boy is
where he keeps his uh where he does hot
yoga once a month in
there it is older wiser grayer look at
that
wow
look at that a little older a little
wiser a lot grayer i said it looks like
father time beat the [ __ ] ups with his
dick we're as gray as that [ __ ] wolf
dude look how great you are that gray is
that wolf blame it on the light but it's
not though right well
the light takes some responsibility and
eddie be a better photographer
i don't know if you can blame that on
anybody is it my phone that's what you
know that's what you look like i hate to
tell you
yeah
here's what's interesting the only thing
like even jamie in the back has gray's
yes he does a little older a little
thicker okay everyone's a little thicker
no i'm saying everybody except for your
daddy well no that day just looks like
you look like you've aged 30 years since
last game and i have in the face and i
have it's all i mean you just look older
there yeah
we all look older
look at eddie he's being completely gray
it's crazy rogan looks exactly the same
exactly the same might be in better
shape
yeah he looks tremor that's what i'm
saying because he's eating meat and
fruit sure he's on a lot of stuff we're
uh we're we're having steak and i said
uh i said i'll get the broccoli and he
goes um i said you don't eat broccoli
goose it's famine food because most
plants toxic you can eat every animal on
the planet i was like okay interesting
that's all you gotta know i mean i'm a
carnivore guy too works for me we had
some i can't wait we did four over four
and a half hours four and a half hours
when he was like all right boys that's
it i was like it felt like we were only
an hour in well then we then we went to
dinner and did another four hours and
and alex jones alex jones and eddie did
four hours alex jones kind of we were
more like eddie on the actual campaign
because eddie was going off he had a few
drinks at dinner and i was like eddie
where was this energy on the companion
he's like sometimes it's like listen bro
i'm like no man it was good though i
want the crazy eddie well well eddie
eddie i love eddie yeah the best and
eddie what we'll do next time is we'll
have eddie close the show out a half
hour in we get him drunk enough yeah we
used to do that and he'll go off on on
everything once the fights are over
you're just like eddie how about this
freaking virus going on and then it's
game on but won't we get flagged for
that sir
uh on youtube uh we'll uh think boy
would but spotify won't where it goes
right b right so but it's live on
youtube as well does it can't fly your
live video you can't no what are you
gonna do i don't know it's also rogan
what are you gonna do it doesn't matter
so the way it works is rogan's deal he
can do live events on youtube but then
people are like oh where's that because
if you didn't watch it live then it gets
uploaded spotify and audio and the full
videos on spotify so his deal which is
insane deal he can do live fight
campaigns and you know because spotify
doesn't have the capabilities do live
but youtube does so you can do it live
on youtube since spotify can't do that
yeah but as soon as it's over it's
uploaded to spotify so if like people
are hitting us up and dm's like dude how
can i watch it it's like spotify man
yeah but it was on youtube just because
it's live
that makes sense yes man tears is doing
really well guys 162 000 love it brother
162 thousand yeah all right six two
thousand yeah
that would be a bummer
yeah but rogan can move the needle and
it's doing really well i guess most of
the comments are overwhelming in the
positives tell the comments buddy
i don't who you talking to i'm
definitely right i'm talking to you 154
okay
not bad i'll take it yeah i'll take it
got a bunch of podcasts to do and uh
it's gonna be fun you'll line up a
little little tour
joey diaz
stepping on my here's my thing about it
yeah you didn't send me and the boys
like uh trailer to post a flyer you need
to do that i just don't but it should
have been last week right right but i
should have had this last week i have it
but you just don't send anybody i don't
know if that was appropriate
to my friends to put on your po on your
feed
did you post the trailing thing on your
social media yeah yeah i did all that
see i don't see it if you sent to me
because i don't you know i don't see
anything so yeah if you just send it to
us you know yeah but you could even send
like boys it's out you know and then
just let people don't force don't i've
never asked anybody hey make sure you
post this never okay just like hey it's
that like you know take a look let me
and then people do whatever they want
with it all right but yeah just
definitely give me some of that
like the trailer should be in today's
episode
well i have it here since the chin well
when we're done though yeah okay yeah or
we can close the show with that oh that
makes sense yeah all right i'll do 100
so you get the views on this you're
right
that's the move daddy you're right buddy
you're right you're 100 right
um and now i was uh telling my girl when
we were so there's austin like when i
come into town and i do vulcan right
there's austin i stay
kind of on
around 6th street yes and then there's
rogan's austin right and he's the
governor of texas now which is awesome
so we run the town when we're there yeah
but if we're not with him we don't run
the town so he runs the town everybody
asks him for everything which i told him
it's exhausting i feel bad for him but
even the restaurant owner is like hey
can you do this for me i'm like dude
this is terrible but with rogan when
you're with him i call my girl like i
could see living in austin she's like
now you can't have him before i'm like
before it was during the pandemic
lockdowns i'm like on like the outskirts
like where he's at that makes sense yeah
i i i'm a fan of awesome people talk
about how hot it is have you been out
here
in the valley today oh yeah i live out
here right so you could you could hold
on but yesterday was 113. okay 113
degrees 113. 113. i know it's hot when
i'm on the beach and it's hot as [ __ ]
where my dogs are i feel like it's the
hottest it's ever been
probably i feel like this is the hottest
i've i've been in california what 12
years now i've never been this hot ever
in my life and i blame biden for it
i love when they blame politics for it
look i mean this is why we've got to
vote a certain way unless you guys want
to you know roast and just be under a
hot lamp for the rest of your [ __ ]
life and die yeah the run with it
dude you gotta watch that impeachment
show on fx it's not hulu but with about
the monica lewinsky my mom's at the end
of it but they show like real clips and
then i started you know because i get
balls deep in so then i'll watch like
the actual like interviews that like
hillary clinton did you know stand by
her man which bill clinton came out
people like liked him more after that
and disliked her because they felt like
she was like kind of like pluggy mcgee
like you were jerry i felt like she was
like really mcgee yeah they're like well
this isn't natural like
mcgee a little pluggy mcgee so so our
boy he's here and aj's buddy dom the
hypnotist
is hold on hold on yeah hypnotist no
he's he's a site he he's a performance
psychologist but you know it's just
that's a catchy word
right he's he's smart and he goes
whenever brian has to promote he's so
uncomfortable with it
that he and he always interrupts yeah he
does it the worst time yeah it's
literally like like we were talking
about cars you're like speaking of and
you're like whoa
because i'm so i just hate it yeah i
hate it like you say why didn't you send
a trailer
uh good question dude maybe because i
have these weird mentalities you also
didn't think i bet you didn't think
about it i was thinking about it
constantly but i just like dude it was
ruining every day just lining up a
podcast to ruin my day
cause me so much anxiety nothing works
i'm just like hey if you guys have an
opening that's why it'd be nice if
people knew you had a special girl and
they'd reach out to you that's not
really how everyone's so busy
everybody's good no so the night
somebody goes you have a special you
want to come on but you have to reach it
it's on me you just feel like it's an
[ __ ] it's fine you know it's it it's
it's all good you you i have a lot of
friends and people who you know yeah but
that's the but that's the way you make a
special to me successful is like
you your your friends all blasted out
like you we have a community you know
so your friends should show support get
on that yeah maybe let's take a little
break from just chat let's just take a
break
austin i like it guys
you know man tears is available out
there it is your special's available
right now jump on it baby it's on
youtube anywhere you get your youtube
we're going to be you can be in appleton
wisconsin appleton wisconsin this
thursday friday saturday appleton
wisconsin won't be so freaking hot there
and i'm in ontario ontario improv is
next week next thursday friday saturday
then i end september in boston that's
laugh boston september 29th through
october 1st and then we just add new
dates in october we have san jose salt
lake city and then also it's not on
there right now but calgary canada is on
there as well get you some tickets at
the boy.com we also got the thick boy
annual labor day sale going on right now
so head to thick boy get you some stuff
well you know it's going to be real hot
in raleigh north carolina the community
the humanities the humidity meter hits
red hot but you know the comedy meter is
hitting red your nuts are going to stick
to your leg my nuggets are going to
stick like when i'm on stage at good
nights september 8 9 and 10. so get your
tickets then we got san jose california
the following weekend september 15 16 17
then we got specan washington speaking
comedy club and then tacoma washington i
don't stop i go i stay in washington if
i want
september 29th october 1st then
bridgeport connecticut october 13 14 15.
come get some kids
i'm looking forward to that yeah you
like football dude dude i can't wait the
nfl season's here my bronco's gonna be
good with russell wilson i can watch the
broncos and make money with my friends
at draftkings they are official sports
betting partner of the nfl and they're
giving you guys new customers that can't
miss offer to celebrate the return of
the nfl right now new customers can bet
just five dollars you 200 dollars and
free bets instantly
and as an added bonus one week all right
week one everyone can experience the
thrill of draftkings early win promotion
it's simple bet on nfl team to win if
your team leads by 10 at any point of
the game they don't even have to win as
long as they're up by 10 at any point of
the game you get paid instantly even if
they lose and also yeah ufc 279 this
week you got hamzat nate diaz is your
main event baby if you want to make
money on that nate is a big dog he's a
plus
675 so you've got 100 you win 675 bucks
if he's gonna win doing the later rounds
all right so download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
fighter you get 200 in free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet this sunday that's coach fighter
only at draftking sportsbook an official
sports brand part of the nfl minimum age
eligibility restriction supply see show
notes for details see you next page for
directions with disclaimer download
draftking sportsbook app now use pro
code fighter
look is the piece of plastic in your
wallet doing enough for you that's the
question
with secure chime
chime credit
builder visa credit card you can build
start building credit with everyday
purchases
and on time payments dude that's the
magic of the credit builder you increase
your credit history with no annual fees
or interest and having a higher credit
score listen credit is fantastic get
better car loan rates renting apartments
is easier what are you trying to do you
need good credit also a little brag
around the table at the dinner table
dude right so continue your credit
journey score all right continue your
credit journey with chime sign up takes
two minutes you got two minutes to have
great credit it doesn't affect your
credit score either get started chime
dot com fighter that's chime dot com
slash fighter
and then you read that brian chime
credit builder visa credit card is
issued by stride bank and a pursuant of
a license with visa usa time checking
account and 200 qualifying direct
deposit required to apply to secured
chime credit builder visa credit card
regular time on-time payment history can
have a positive impact on your credit
score impact of to score may vary and
some use the scores may not improve
that's chime dot com slash fighter chime
on
yeah yeah it'd be fun but yeah that so
that monica lewinsky thing
it's interesting because uh god [ __ ]
bill clinton and you know you remember
he was a lord uh
hillary clinton was a lawyer like the
smart people man yeah so when they when
they do like the mock like prosecution
what they're going to ask when they're
on trial and they do the mock thing and
they're like did you ever have sexual
relations with mark lewinsky now i'm
watching the real one this isn't the
show and i'm like there's no way he's
gonna get out it's clearly he has dick
sucked all the time and there's the
dress with the dna on it but they find
the nuances in what the prosecution says
and he sat down with them way before he
was in the deposition dude way before so
he goes
verbal jiu-jitsu well no he said their
term of sexual relations
doesn't quantify it doesn't relate to
this my art my term is different third
term of sexual relations meant penis to
vagina contact that and he never had sex
with he goes that never happened so he
was so i'm not lying under oath
according to their definition he's
amazing i did not have sexual relations
and you're like
it was the first time
it was the first time i realized what
mental what what verbal jiu-jitsu was
yeah like they always say so i know a
guy
who is a high-level elite dude he's a
he's a billionaire and he deals with all
the richest people in the world he said
the two smartest people he's ever met
ever uh of everybody's met from bill
gates he's not a first-name basis with
everybody he said
michael milken at the milken institute
he's the guy the junk bond guy who went
away
and and then got prostate cancer and
created like the biggest he's
responsible for more research and more
progress in prostate cancer he's just a
genius in everything he does
and he said
uh michael milken bill gates bill gates
my buddy david steinberg said that
[ __ ] on like that's how that's
how smart he is he goes he said i've
never seen anybody who can talk
so in such depth about
any subject what do you want to talk
about
biology or business
right up there if you're gonna battle
them on things you better come with the
weapon well because you'll find yourself
halfway through you're like [ __ ]
well you know because they keep like
going backwards the smartest people in
the world and yes it you know for him
he's how many hours he's been spending
he's talking to the smartest brains in
the world when you're texting with mark
zuckerberg and elon musk you're going to
learn some things
my favorite dick pic
he's all goddamn this is the best after
the podcast
rogan is playing [ __ ] uh
pool
first of all i'm hungry
and he's just shooting poor brian i
haven't eaten all day i fasted i worked
out in the morning we did a you'd be
proud i did a uh a workout inside the i
didn't know rogan had his own 24 hour
fitness otherwise i just went to the 24
hour it was 25 the biggest team you've
got 24 hours how many bags how many bags
10 bags how many does ufc gym have
correct twice that so
so i didn't know there was a gym that so
i worked out did a
hotel work out the town like body squats
and push them stuff yeah you could get
sweat in you know because that's that's
one of my sharpest when the boat yeah
blood gets flowing then i get there and
we brian i didn't eat at all at all four
half hour probably were drinking
nicotine rogue [ __ ] whiskey also [ __ ]
we've done i look around i'm [ __ ]
starting mine's like me too
can't wait
and then so the gym you know it's it's
where you would you could keep a boeing
747 correct you could keep several of
them yes
so
so he's shooting pool and i'm like and i
a couple times i go hey let's go eat man
i want to eat i'm starting to get angry
yeah
and
so joe
drops
some scientific
knowledge that's not made it in the
public sphere yet he goes this could
blow apart a lot of
what science says about certain things
but it's a little technical
yeah
and i can see shaab i don't know why but
shav is just he just wants to get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah and i was starving
and also i'm into a lot of things his
fact was
fascinating if it's true mind like
you'll change
the trajectory like history a lot of
people built their careers have to be
[ __ ] oh i'm wrong everything i've done
i'll tell you off here but because we
can't
me and him definitely can't leak it but
this is exciting no
well don't get too excited but so i was
like hey if you're into you know if
you're into if if
listen it's not going to affect your
life at all no no you keep living it
doesn't affect anything people are going
to have to rewrite the history books but
for me it was just
i'm not like space and wormholes and
okay you might there's nothing i can do
about it so i don't care also most
people go yeah i figured i mean yeah i i
guess
like that
yeah okay if i said that to you you if i
said that to you and i went look at this
you'd go you'd go ah wow cool hey do we
have to can we get some coffee like it
would be that
but
so but wrote it's hitting with this
so so he's playing pool which he's very
good at yeah and he's in a food coma
so he's just sitting and he's tired
my blood sugar i want the big man breaks
down yeah well
yeah i get done an eight hour pocket i
get if i'm into it i can go but once we
stop yeah and i'm chilling and there's
no plan and you're just playing pool
yeah what are we doing here wait wait
when you say brendan breaks down
there's not a mission yeah he's going to
bed right no if there's not a mission if
there's not a mission be done and
if there's a if there's a meal to be had
and a couple drinks we're good yeah he's
going to go there it might not be that
talkative by the way after four and a
half hours you might just want to sit
and just watch and just kind of be there
right yeah but then you're not getting
them to go
anywhere else after that he's not
standing i was quiet at dinner i was
quiet just because
several reasons yeah i felt bad for
rogan yeah be honest i felt bad for her
when you're when you're as famous i was
always mad i was mad when you're famous
as jokes everybody wants something i
don't care who it is the restaurant
owner whoever it might be yeah including
me the guy thought of his friend come to
ask him for stuff and i was just like
god i was just staring out it like
pissed me off yeah it's just it's just
what it is it broke my heart to be
honest was that the main incident of the
evening or was there other stuff like
that
that was the other people getting stuff
it's it's not it's not stopped yeah i
just felt bad everybody wants him on the
podcast everybody wants to get on the
podcast he lies the crown yeah yeah so i
just felt bad for him so i was quiet i
was mad to be honest but my but the
[ __ ]
rogan drops this little nugget of
information and the enthusiasm
coming out of [ __ ] left field over
here i mean i i started laughing so hard
because because he's trying to he's
trying to act excited because there's no
one saying anything yeah but you know
you don't want to make your friend feel
bad that's why i was going i'm saying
nothing so he goes right he goes he goes
first of all i'm on my phone
yeah so he's like he's doing this he's
like doing this he goes
man
those guys are [ __ ]
just raised in those scientists
are you imagining
then he goes
yeah and i was just looking at i'm going
like this i'm going wow dude you're
[ __ ] enthusiastic
about this [ __ ]
the dinner was good though the dinner
was great it was you know what it was i
realized about what i loved about that
podcast with you me and eddie but and
but especially
no that's all but like i realize with
certain friendships i think what it
comes down to is when all the noise
stops
we all come back to a default and the
default is we all agree basically on the
same values and on the same set point
like no matter what's going on there's a
lot of nonsense in the world and you
always have somebody you can go like
this with rogan was always that guy you
can always come back and go hey
we're here
like i'm here and i'm this is home
because i know here is where all the all
the noise
it's a safe space yeah but also it's
like the four of us together like
rogan's not the most famous guy on the
planet no one's trying there's no gotchu
moments there's no gossip there's no
drama there's no
uh you know it's honest it's just a good
time yeah who knows where the thing is
well i think what it is is the fight
companion is exactly what we'd be like
at dinner if no cameras are on that's
the difference oh the fight man after at
the dinner with alex jones would have
been even bigger yeah that was crazy we
were straight up yelling at each other
alex alex alex is such a character he's
so funny i'm reading his book
i'm fine i left mine at the hotel i'm
finding it interesting
i think it's good even if you're not or
even if you don't agree with all this
stuff obviously the sandy hook stuff i
completely disagree with but the rest of
it like
you know to rogan's point he's a lot on
him he's right on a lot of stuff the
problem is
because he's right on certain things
people think he's right on everything
it's the thing for himself so then
that's when it gets dicey
well my fundamental disagreement with
most conspiracy guys or people like that
is that they
there's a simplification between good
guys and bad guys and there are bad guys
there are the elites and i don't
complicate like they're fluffy are there
bad people in politics absolutely
people done conspiracy did cia were they
in on the jfk killing 110 percent it
doesn't mean they're always in on it
doesn't mean they're across the board
it's on it well yeah i just think
it's it's a lot more complicated and i
chalk up a lot more of [ __ ] to
incompetence and chance and and what's
called black swan events actually you
don't see coming yeah i agree there's
those curveballs but i also think
conspiracy theories are more fun dude
it's more interesting it's a community
around it and there's also anybody can
ride with it because
all right prove it well not only that if
you believe in conspiracy theories
nobody can say i got you i fooled you
it's like i see what's going on you guys
are [ __ ] with me it's like the magic
guy you know the magic trick people like
i know he does that
yeah
listen there are a lot of conspiracies i
agree with them you know but some of it
i don't but a lot of them are [ __ ]
fun a lot of them are very true you know
but then some just out like you know who
have draw lines somewhere fellas
somewhere
yeah
so his books the great reset
yeah it's it's uh i like the he uses a
very very interesting analogy and it's
something i had just read about in the
old testament alex is pretty religious i
think
he talks about god a lot up in dallas
yeah it makes sense and and he he used
an interesting analogy which is that in
the book in the old testament in the in
in judges in the book of samuel
god gets mad at the israelites because
the israelites want a king and god says
you don't need a king if you follow
the rules i've set for you
because if you follow the rules i've set
for you you will be your own king you
will you will be if you are a virtuous
person you will have a virtuous society
austin 360 and favorite verse and he
also [ __ ] but he draws a very
interesting comparison and it's true the
founding fathers talked about this the
founding fathers said
that if you have if you are a virtuous
person if you read if you if you live a
virtuous life
you will then govern yourself in a
virtuous way and if enough men in a
society do that we will have
a virtuous society that would be the
idea and it was a big topic like for
four people you know in that sense and
he says that if you look at the world
economic forum and you look at a lot of
the the there are there's a very strong
out the idea out there that the elites
should run everything that the elites
the people who are the quote-unquote
smartest the philosopher kings
should be the ones to ultimately come up
with policies
rules and governance
that make it so and they couch it this
way so that we don't have to think about
it that we're all going to be equal and
that no we will all be happy we won't
own anything and he's right
yeah
he's right he is right to say that is a
very dangerous
idea and i agree with him on that and
it's the fundamental difference between
what the individual being the most
important thing and the individual and
it's his rights over state rights
over the idea that the [ __ ] state
that your government your central
government knows what's best for you
no sorry [ __ ]
that's where you go that's where you got
to be careful there's all this
technology you know this dude you've
seen this thing this [ __ ] thing the
line that in saudi arabia they're
designing listen to this it's a city
but the city
is a straight line
it's walls higher than the empire state
building
over 200 meters wide look this up
and it's [ __ ] sick because it's and
then everything you don't need a car
everything is connected with a high
speed rail
and it's be 150 miles long or something
crazy like that or even longer
and everything you need everything is
housed within like five minutes from you
your school your hospital your groceries
everything and it's just like one and
then they have like bring it up you can
see that you can see the actual like
small town
it says 9 million it's 9 million people
it's actually genius in a weird way
because it's it's totally sustainable
it's green and you don't need a car you
can get everywhere on a high-speed rail
i don't want that though look at this
look at this look at this would be the
city but why is that to be a straight
line well i think in the desert it would
be the idea would be that it's much
easier to supply it's it's got a zero
carbon footprint all that [ __ ] look at
that vehicle-free city but but bring up
like the prototypes of what it's going
to look like
it's it and and they have they have a
way to keep the the ceiling open so it's
uh and they keep their cars no streets
yeah
so it's disneyland it's
disneyland it's kind of it's very
intriguing like look at that [ __ ] it's
got greenery everywhere and it's just
one big it's a it's the line look at
that
[ __ ]
i think it's gonna it might it's gonna
be really interesting to see what we do
with the future that would be what you
would be looking up at see that and the
temperature would always be kept at a
certain degree and it'd be it'd be good
is it enclosed
it's not it doesn't have to be enclosed
because of the way they design it um so
you you somehow keep the air circulating
and fresh but it's all like zero carbon
somehow
look at that [ __ ]
that's pretty impressive
106 mile long vertical city
now
here's the problem
it's really easy to have surveillance on
everything you do
facial recognition yeah everything
you don't need locks everything's with
your face
weird it's pretty easy to live that way
watch this
let's see if it works we lost about
everything it's an ad
this is an ad
so after this
are you allowed to show this i don't
know we'll see yeah it's called i'll
just chop it up
um initially scheduled for 2025 delays
have pushed back yeah
i mean it's
another 2030. it's kind of crazy but
it's it's it's i it looked like a cool
place to live
move there
what do i do hold on you move there
austin you're like i can't decide all
right dude look saudi arabians look
great or austin look
just 34 square kilometers you know easy
that's going to blow up no if you're a
terrorist shut up brennan why are you
such a hater on the future dude
i don't get that dude i don't know if
the straight line you and me there dude
come on
no i like to drive look at that 1600
feet high 660 feet wide you know what i
don't like you know i don't like what
how excited you are about that mirrored
glass facade dude
100 renewable energy and could
potentially house not you love polluting
the planet you pieces [ __ ] shut up you
love polluting the planet you pieces of
pollution look i knew it
yeah it's a mega civilization you want
to live in a mega civilization no i
don't you know what else is it's
dystopian things look the same yeah have
you ever seen wreck-it ralph 2 yeah yeah
no but i don't know i'm gonna say yeah
it's the exact same thing 500 billion
dollars
is that it
dude
let's invest
i mean that does nothing for me really
that didn't show us anything dude it's a
straight line looks like sim city huh
they could play
on the wall they could play man tears on
the whole [ __ ] thing across
yeah the whole world hello thanks yeah
that'd be cool thanks saudi arabia
thanks saudi arabia oh wait but it's
coming on two on 30
and promote my special in eight years by
that time i'll have seven 70 million
views yep
yeah i don't know if i live in the
straight line huh i don't know if i want
to live in the straight line you're
gonna i'm just trying to get to austin i
think yeah you liked it uh i don't know
at least it's so hot right here right
you know where we're at right it's so
hot yeah
i know and it's september but let me ask
you so much october was hot as [ __ ] i
remember trick or treating my kids sweat
my ass off and that [ __ ] star was
outfit
i guess traffic is a lot lighter in
austin for now
all right traffic here
i don't work at nine to five it's not a
huge deal for me but you're the west
side right now it's 1 30. get there in
35 minutes so gun to your head you go to
austin what do you have in austin you
don't have in in saudi and money
no
in l.a taxes
taxes newsome
yeah garcetti for now yeah well he's not
coming out there
yeah i don't know i think austin's going
to be
you know well it'll never be it's
already pretty late
yeah well oh super liberal especially
inside also with outskirts you know
you're good yeah but
i mean
yeah i don't know dude probably just
talking [ __ ] yeah i wouldn't leave
anytime soon now
i'd like that setup
the studio yeah i don't know what to do
with it
because his his where he records is the
same size as this but just finding the
kids that's what i thought was
impressive it was like just pretty
rudimentary same [ __ ] and it's nice
that's his style has all his art and
stuff but that's what you want for him
that's what you because
the match you have is four it's not like
he has multiple shows like i do like i
need where we have six studios here
because of all that other [ __ ] yeah he's
just just his one show
so you can focus on that all his art is
sick because even when i was there pro
my especially in april it's changed
since then
it's gotten even more big boy yeah
is there a joe experience
jesus christ
sick yeah he's
superstar
yeah
his superstar
um well that's it i'm dropping the uh
i'm dropping
my [ __ ] tim kennedy thing
messed up tomorrow or maybe even today i
don't know yet
is it on
is it on the same youtube as your
special youtube yeah it's brian count
wait yes
who is helping you don't comment don't
commit to that i mean oh you know this
is what you should do so the thing you
want to do the best make sure it goes to
the bottom as you keep putting out
videos that you don't really care about
do that if you're special but do that
who is helping you i don't know nobody
nobody
yeah so don't do that no okay
all right now wait on it
when uh i was gonna say i'm gonna hit
you best step going to drop tim kennedy
probably sabotage your [ __ ] special
for mine we didn't put anything out for
i mean i don't know a week okay yeah
because it think about it on the main
page you can get knocked down see i
didn't think about that did i
need to have like the thumbnail up on
your youtube which i'm sure you've done
that right your whole special on
thumbnail yeah
like i said guys uh
best level drop in a week
so
let that special breathe where are you
headed to this week b
i'm going to raleigh buddy thursday
there yeah i looked i'm inhuman let's
not forget yeah yep north carolina's hot
you're gonna sweat and you can sweat
hard it's hot i looked up appleton not
bad high of 82. you're gonna like
yeah you're gonna love the city whatever
but the the club is great
see but i like the chill cities i don't
like the chaotic [ __ ] yeah
i like this one i like good restaurants
for food is the only thing you know
if they just have like one local like
it's like you know the line in saudi
arabia it's like one street i don't like
that coffee shops walk just the street
yeah thank you for bringing the line
from saudi arabia back to you i like
that full come back that's a good call
back bubba
that's a good callback you're going to
the malibu chili cook-off yeah yeah
last night i saw j-lo and uh and and big
ben just [ __ ] walking hand-in-hand
when was that the malibu cook-off batman
himself and nobody was bugging him now i
saw adam sandler there two two years ago
or whatever longer than that yeah
whenever two years i couldn't believe
how [ __ ] uh
i couldn't believe it
it's like you can't leave that guy alone
for a couple of seconds he's with his
family it's honestly malibu is pretty
chill
it it is except for when it comes to
that guy i'm talking about like like i
don't know 50 people massive people
bother with his kids like let the [ __ ]
kick out in chaos
but not in a bad way it's not first of
all they got metal detectors which i
very much appreciate and they got swat
guys walking around with [ __ ] guns i
was over there using my kiddos for the
cars
sorry i was i was there yesterday before
because i think the cookoff starts at
one i was there at like 11. right when
we land i went straight there with the
kiddos yep i've noticed now that police
like you don't you're not at one of
those places ever without a [ __ ] load of
police presence and they look like
they're young dudes ready to go oh yeah
they're not like you need training i'm
out of shape no doubt eating no no i
don't want somebody with a i don't want
something with a belly and a [ __ ] 38
i want dudes with with dip like clips
extra clothes these guys look like
they're chomp at the [ __ ] yeah like
you're like in shape crossfit dudes just
with good hair like the probability of
them shooting somebody very high and
probably on action yes yeah if florida
is the greatest because those dudes will
just wear a vest in a very tight tank
top
and they'll have their gun on their
[ __ ] leg yeah i like that but bring
this see if you can bring those [ __ ]
guys up from florida i don't know what
they are they're vice or some [ __ ]
they're jacked out of their minds shaved
forearms tan of [ __ ] well now even down
hollywood i was i went to get coffee at
alfred's off melrose the other day and
the the shops around this they have big
boy security big boys let me just hang
out front yeah jesus christ and which i
appreciate i like it yeah that lady's
hands are not talking about the best
pictures advice
that's gonna protect your miami you're
right b
some ladies
are here dude
um
vice swat there's a new thing among the
kids i don't know if you've seen they've
been but they're getting the old uh
vaping and [ __ ] they've been [ __ ]
euphoria thank you but no look at this
well now these guys have sleeveless
shirts but those guys look ready to rock
yeah they also look off duty i like how
everyone's different ethnicity too what
are we saying right they they have uh
white they have uh
white whoa
special weapons and tactics team
they have [ __ ] uh have you seen this
thing this this nose piercing no it's a
nose well
we saw it at the airport that gallow had
that nose piercing that went like this
it was like a staple it was like
somebody's staples
oh but it's real small it's in the front
it looks like somebody took a staple oh
i didn't see that girl i pointed you
that skinny girl i thought you were
making fun of that i was just the whole
get up was that the whole get up was it
was
like who she had a staple on her [ __ ]
nose it was very interesting right and
then i went to the cookoff and i saw
three girls in the front that that [ __ ]
which one
it's it's on top of the nose
like that there's some pictures of it
like that but it's a staple
just like a big thick staple literally i
like the little one if i do a stapler in
my chicken on your nose that's what kids
are doing yeah
i don't care they're eating tie-dye
[ __ ] i just look at that girl go back
up right there here no over there yeah
right your kids doing tie-dye pockets
yeah that one the other one too vaping
how about rogan's vaping rogan's vaping
i couldn't believe you talk about that
thing on the top of the nose there yeah
yeah yeah like that little bridge though
but it's not as pretty i'm talking about
staple
yeah i typed in staple but let's see
the nose
the point is i figured out what i'm
going to get for my nose
i'm not seeing a lot of it but you're
saying these young people the malibu
cook i just saw i don't know i think
it's a new thing because i saw three of
the kids at the or i saw a total of
three people on a sunday not these right
bro nope not that no he's talking about
straight up staple across the nose yeah
i mean it's very distracting you only
take it so far let's go to black
stainless steel nose right there
black stainless steel nose i don't see
which one you're talking about b the one
up there and etsy right there yeah there
you go are you talking about that time
piece yes
yes that's the problem is people doing
it they don't look like that no some of
them did
very pretty girls
i'd hate to be a 15 16 year old oh so
you're saying they do like that top
metal bracket so what we're looking at
is a girl so i think when
i think it's attractive when they get
that little piercing here i don't mind
it but then make it go all the way
across the side to change what it is
it's like the line in saudi arabia
it's not the thing
dude your callbacks are good
thank you bro yes
they and it's awesome it's a fractal
eco-friendly you are correct sir yes now
she's got a very strong jaw she does uh
that costs a lot of money to do that
costs a lot of holly jenner draw yeah
that's gonna hurt it's gonna take some
time away they're gonna put some filler
in there right a couple days off from
work if they have to reshape your jaw
are you saying that there's some work
done on those lips and that that just
cheek bones
to
it it's very expensive with the quagmire
draw effect like that yeah that's a
that's very expensive now she's very
attractive yes she is
she screams trauma
you think so a lot of trauma i would
imagine you got it she looks like she
didn't have a dad in her life well she's
done a lot of decorations tattoos just
yell out i need help and this would be
one of them right the head tattoo the
deck tattoo the piercing cross now her
eyebrows are tattooed as well right
because those aren't real cause nobody
has eyebrows like that no now see here's
the problem with me if you look at my
past i was drawn to that i was like you
look like a train wreck
maybe really get into a relationship
sure yeah
what's the what's the red flag tattoo on
guys you think
face
toy space
face tattoos usually point to something
going on it depends if they get out of
like a bentley like my guy's doing
something right i think
honda's everything maybe yeah
but you see a lot of people not a bank
teller with a face tattoo see i feel
like face tattoos are coming more more
normal again thank you for you these
kids do these kids suck in [ __ ]
vaping dude yes i say it all the time
yeah
i i think still a face tattoo is a
strange commitment it depends it depends
it really depends is it a form of
self-loathing though that's beyond what
most people do or they look up to like a
post malone or travis barker yeah
because post malone like all the young
rappers have face tattoos so you know
it's that thing so it's a style it's a
it's a style thing
face tattoos neck tattoos so there's
more our buddy crystal you got that
tattoo like tattoos are like a i would
love a neck tattoo yes you would i would
love yes don't
don't oh just a feather don't though
just a native mirror we're getting too
old now for that stuff yeah you're still
covered up though it's not a big deal
just covering your turtlenecks in the
middle of there's makeup
excuse me i can't wear makeup on stage
just you use me and then also if i'm
rocking the tattoo here that i go on
stage with with my people like do you
have makeup all over your neck yeah you
can't tell
this is like my tattoo cover up oh chin
wants a tattoo on his neck that's why i
want my entire body but i'm saying like
they know you you're already like you're
known so it's fine that's a good tattoo
you have you want your whole body tap i
don't know are you gonna go on trt and
start lifting again i'm already on crt
baby [ __ ] yeah for like a month already
jim what's like the yakuza thing he
wants the inside of his ass i don't want
that you should get that whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa how are you wait a minute so
you're right are you lifting weights as
well now come on brian you are dude you
look good thanks bro are you lifting
yeah
and this is mark harley helping you of
course i talked to marcos that's
beautiful
you and jamie should have come out with
like advice yeah you and jamie should
have a competition because you did one
with nick to lose weight and our buddy
nick who's the producer king sting lost
all the weight he lost he looked like
much weight it looked like he had he
took this weight loss challenge so
serious bro he went from what
all i know his hand like 168 or
something he lost like 28 pounds
20 pounds in five weeks i was like he
when he showed up what happened are you
okay did you do you have monkey box are
you okay he looked so sick like his neck
was like this big yeah his face is his
mouth because nick's a big handsome guy
he was like i haven't eaten in three
weeks i like him at 210 he's norwegian
he's big
[Music]
he's like six one six two though yeah
he's like six two yeah no no
um
chin yeah you look good thanks trt and
up how do you feel what's the difference
i'm on like the lowest possible dose
just to sleep better
no my thing my main reason why i want to
go on it is because of my mood i'm just
like i don't have the best mood yeah
for a little bit yeah so i'm hoping
it'll
i would say
so hopefully like two months i'll feel
better yeah i'm surprised you didn't
feel instantly energized
you're you're doing some different [ __ ]
though you know what you're on
recipient
symphony yes all right do adderall and
coke no just kidding just kidding
youtube coffee gets me jittery
oh you can't even drink coffee huh i do
but it gets me jittery that means i
don't walk in adrenals are good
yeah maybe i don't know i'm [ __ ] yeah
all right all right let's take a little
break now that counts go drain the old
gray snake of his and that thing is gray
and old and listen if your brain ain't
firing like it should because you're
getting older
brian you need a little kratom to fire
up your brain that's what i use on all
podcasts man it's my limitless pill i
use it for stand up for podcasts it's
the best focused products the only
focused product i trust and i use all
right kratom it's like cbd used to be
it's though it used to be the wild west
so you got to get aligned with company
that you trust get pure kratom that's
why happy hippo is my number one go-to
for kratom visit happyhippo herbals.com
use promo code thick boy for 20 for life
you can use that code as many times as
you want that's right visit happy hippo
herbals.com use promo code thickboy for
20 off for life use as many times as you
want you're welcome i'm the kratom
dealer happy hippo
you enjoy
but you you should do a competition with
jamie because he's on
some trt too i think he look jacked out
there
so he's lifting a lot then right he
plays a lot of golf and i think yeah he
lives in because you know rogan has that
[ __ ]
yeah global gym i'm just starting to
lift again so you know i'm enjoying it
it's just my freaking pinched nerve crap
that makes it hard so i still try to
work through hey brian who am i ev every
guy
introduces that we met in austin
aren't you not i'm getting back on the
mic i have a neck problem i want to get
back on the mats my [ __ ]
i've been out about two months my elbow
my neck
i have a weird secret uh i have a little
pleasure that i do
well you find out who's at the dinners
and jack offering you back to your room
well that yes of course i do that but
that's different i am
well first of all you're right about jiu
jitsu and crossfit those are the two
things
it's shoulder neck it's back it's
something at me
uh it's fair it's a great sport maybe
it's worth it and it's awesome but i am
i get a kick out of like i was watching
and you were sitting there
and then
everybody there's black belt and trains
a lot
you have to do about nine black belts i
know and i was like and rogan and i was
like brennan stopped training a while
ago
and i was like but you know if i were to
lock the door right now
this is what's going through your head
literally i go and i even said it to
rogan but i go
i want to lock the door right now
brendan could pull everybody's head off
their spine right quick and all that
training would go right back to being
you may as well be me
and i get this kind of like
i'm looking at you and you're all
gigantic over there and you're all like
quite your nails and quiet like we bite
your nails there's too much
hey you all right over there yeah i'm
putting out we got all kinds of [ __ ]
going on a million fighters and and then
i uh i'm watching you and i'm going he
could kill everybody here no matter how
much you train there's a certain amount
of limitation that comes with gravity
size physics
and it was your job for a long time yeah
and i said that to rogue and i go hey go
he could kill everybody here what do we
say
he goes are you fantasizing about being
him
he gets all serious on me because you
enjoying that
i was like all i do is i went
i'll tell you i've never slept so good
in that [ __ ] hotel room that bad
that's called a that's called a four
seasons bed you know they're famous for
that bring up four seasons bed and bring
up how much they [ __ ] cost are the
beds alive because you can i saw a thing
there's a brochure there to buy it bring
it up chin i'm bringing it nice bring it
up oh what's up daddy now i like my
helix i'm not trying to [ __ ] with our
sponsor but
those beds oh it says they use helix
that's cool
if you buy a four season's bed it's
gonna cost you about six grand with
everything i mean the sheets everything
you wanna buy the whole set well they
have these guys
everything their own mattresses oh dude
two thousand two hundred
for this one you're sleeping good daddy
slept oh hard bro seven thousand yeah
there you go seven thousand well it
comes with the sleeping set the whole
thing bro whole thing seven grand
you want your you want your lady to go
ah like if i did that for my girl she
would lose her [ __ ] mind
oh i slept hard in that yeah you can
expect some sleep hard oh
there's there's casper there's casper
yeah is cat are they using casper oh no
but casper's great he looks great
but if you if you want to spend seven
grand we can have we can have a talk
alaskan kane yeah we can have a talk
how's alaskan different than california
it's wider but shorter i don't know
dude i don't want shorter those pillows
nice they got it right you sometimes a
company gets it [ __ ] right yeah just
i like a lot i need about three to four
pillows to sleep when we were in
there was four seasons and those beds my
girl didn't want to go to the bed beds
she'll just lounge around with that baby
i'm sure it's the same same like same
bed the same exact thing yeah so she's
sitting there just lounging around with
baby little fat baby all soft and cute
rolling he's rolling around
she can stay there she can stay there
with that baby for i don't know all day
i could chill in there yeah
the way you look at a ferrari like a
vintage ferrari she sees that bed and
sees her baby and she's like oh boy i
get it yeah me too all right tim what do
you got
okay you guys talking about um rides
like at that chili cook-off whatever
yeah the rides so there's this thing
happening wait do you ride those rides
because i get sick oh you have to do
them boston's too little yeah i'm
curious how many he's gonna be able to
go on it's so small this is not good
this is scary that's why i don't like
doing carnival rides or anything but
this isn't either i just think pros cons
pros
i like those boosts the middle ones yeah
they're expensive yeah these are nice
all right so let's check this out
it's by the way no i don't go on that
[ __ ] that's horrifying dude really
what's up
so there's 30 people injured 10 people
oh no sorry 30 people on the ride 10
people injured but imagine this
happening
oh
oh crazy on the far left as [ __ ]
oh it's so scary i would never go on
this ride how'd this happen
no that'd make me feel sick see the
person well you see on the left they
they're ju all vertebrae
yeah that's gonna be so terrible and
apparently all the the people that
operated the ride they left as soon as
they saw something happening so of
course
of course they're
you're in the traveling circus first of
all they're 16 years old they're perhaps
piercing on their nose they're vaping
trying to [ __ ] and then this [ __ ] breaks
it's happened in india yeah
some countries don't have a whole lot of
stuff i know but if this were to happen
you know what to happen at like the
local fair like i don't want this happen
in malibu although i might get some
money on malibu you want to happen at
like universal studios sue the big boys
oh that's right you want to get some you
want to get your hand you want to get
your beak wet mickey
let splash mountain break but they have
so many precautions you feel so many
[ __ ] problems with the matterhorn
break wait go back to that for a second
i want to just see because you see what
jane fonda was diagnosed with jane fonda
yeah diana go out
cancer chemo oh that's tough she's older
though huh so that's life but uh yeah
that's life um but yep who cares like
hey dude yeah come on be cool we're
younger though here everybody is so we
don't care hey but um remember the kid
it was
you just like you just can't went right
over on all that fitness that's a shame
hey but um remember the big kid in my
was it miami mary he wasn't strapped in
and just came down yeah face first yeah
they're suing for a good amount i i bet
that's something you could you too big
to be on the right though yeah
that kid you're too big though i don't
know because you couldn't lock the seat
belt on the the guy clearly high in
[ __ ] bath salts like yeah you're fine
well have you seen i mean if you get a
job there you're not usually you're a
kid you're definitely high i said to the
guy at the [ __ ] chili cookoff i go
been here since this morning he goes
yeah i go
tough he goes
well that's what edibles are for oh okay
well i was thinking about like when i go
to six flats when on the wooden things
going
all the way at the top i think myself i
wonder how many times that 18 year old
made sure everybody's seat belts
properly yeah strapped on like he's 18
17 i'll give a [ __ ] summer gig trying to
save it by a trans am a nintendo club
you feel me correct yeah it's like what
are we doing man correct
yeah we put so much trust into people
dude the pilot
i'm gonna assume he didn't wasn't out
all night [ __ ] hookers and doing blow
i don't know i have no clue he might be
on a bender now those things sell fly
yeah they do
pilots get too much credit but still
like i could really [ __ ] some stuff up
it's the take off and the landing that
we got to be careful well that's what it
dies in the air that's why the landing
taken infrastructure we benefit from
infrastructure every day and it's a
miracle it all works
and when speaking of traffic control i
don't know if you know how that works
bubba but now i've been on the radio
at lax and i've listened to how much
traffic goes on the fact that we've
never had a mid-air collision
or any of those collisions is a [ __ ]
miracle now there's one in miami today
really yup dp
when you're you're not being respectful
to the dead in the past five minutes
you've been very disrespectful to all
the dead
do you know that jame james plunder's
not dead well you're being a dick she's
gonna beat this dude you're a dick about
the kid who was too big well you're
being a dick now about calling a dp
yeah i don't know if this chin looked
that up and don't knock don't be all
like what
what
you're being a little disrespectful hey
now when you say you had the
we'll call them cans right let's say you
had the cans on the air traffic control
and lx yeah you mean burbank right
because lax doesn't give you that access
right that never happened i mean 100
percent
hey what airport was it john wayne lax
is john wayne no lax because my my dad
my paw oh two small planes don't count
okay
but but but so when you're in when
you're air traffic control right in
when you're air traffic control
pay attention to what i'm saying i am
your finger
when you're not paying attention to a
lot of [ __ ] i'm saying bro and be
affected by my story i'm listening no
you're not being affected by my story i
can't get over the part i don't think
it's lax
i'll tell you i'll call i'm going to
call him ontario airport no no me and my
dad flew in on his plane okay oh that
makes sense oh into the where the all
the commercial flights yeah that makes
sense yes but i'm going to call them to
make sure that's true um we're going to
do it now too
private playing two lax yeah but there's
a there's a private area you can do it
in i'm going to call them right now and
then someone said get the cans on so
you're right yeah i was like i have to
cancel and there's a million planes
going in it's unbelievable
now when you're a trav air traffic
control guy your shifts are how long
four hours ten minutes
oh ten minutes ten minutes so they have
a [ __ ] ton of guys
if you're so you you're so you're air
traffic control you're looking at all
the things you're getting you're making
sure the planes atlanta are in different
areas and plans to take off you're doing
all that [ __ ]
you have a 10-minute shift
guess who's
guess who's behind you touching your
shoulders watching
the guy who's going to take over your
10-minute shift so that guy's there and
he's making sure that you're right so
you have two people so he's calling it
and you have a minder over you who's
watching and and yeah one guy in the
hole yeah now when you apply to be a air
traffic control person if you smoke pot
once if you say you smoke pot
once you can't do it there's almost a
my my nephew my by marriage he they he
said he was honest they go
see ya
and he had to reapply and reapply i mean
you know they don't [ __ ] around and you
want to be air traffic control yeah
it's a [ __ ] it should be it sure
i mean the you're responsible with tons
of lives
i'm dealing with spare airlines delta
united southwest in and out
i believe you're dead
you don't call them you want to make
sure maybe on your own
don't worry
it's a nice little break
guys
guys uh
did you and i get on a plane
did you and i fly into lax together in
your plane
no
no
oh [ __ ] i thought we did
i i i i couldn't do it until lax i
wouldn't even choose to do it i'd go to
burbank with my plane i would have gone
to burbank yeah just like i said uh or
one of the other events
orange county yeah the smaller one of
the other uh
satellite
airports were private i just on the
podcast i just said that we flew into
lax and that i had i listened to all the
air traffic controllers and i guess i
was lying about that so thanks for
exposing me on my own show
no we we didn't but you would have
listened to all the los angeles
controllers because
until you're in and final approach on
one of their runways you're being
controlled by the same guys as the big
guys are thank you that's what i thought
thank you for vindicating i'll see you
later i gotta go back to my podcast and
thanks for raising me appreciate it
thanks for being my dad
bye daddy he's just hung up
hey but right right so when you say i'm
not paying attention because we don't
have to lie right yeah and everyone in
here knew that right and i didn't we
can't move past that to acknowledge that
lax doesn't give people that access
especially you and your dad on the small
private jet would not fly no there's
also a possibility my dad could be wrong
i don't know dude
your dad was like that didn't make sense
we flew in a smaller airport burbank
although i must all the airports i
listed fat eyes on the cans i guess
that's what i heard as we were coming in
uh-huh so it was all that
yeah so that counts
when was this
man
long time ago
i'm just curious probably when you're
young probably i'll tell you exactly
what it was it was when i had a ford
bronco
and i remember my dad going you know you
could afford to get a better car
do you not care about cars at all
i was like
no because it was so dirty it has to be
eighties i mean bronco's been out since
the [ __ ] nah this was in the 90s 90s
yeah hot second ago [ __ ] hospitals
lax though you know but you know but
yeah just common sense really yeah i
hate that i'm right it bothers me that
i'm right you know what i'm saying it
bothers me i know when you're lying i'm
not lying i just thought i
remember i had to clarify it
and then i you know you know we came
clean yeah well your dad was like
absolutely not what i meant was i had
climbed over i had flown over it and i
was talking to them today
god what's the next one
[ __ ] it's the next one so chris rock
and uh deschapelle they're on tour
together so chris rott chris rock
addressed you know the whole apology
video during his stand up and he said
right here i mean will smith should
expect this two comics they're going to
light you up a little bit man for
slapping him yeah embarrass him so the
rocky took the stage first dedicated a
small portion of his lengthy set uh to
talk about will smith during what she
said [ __ ] your hostage video agree an
apparent response to actors viral
youtube apology video smith posted the
apology on youtube in july this first
time rock is directly addressed the
video in public
um the queen noted that the sting effect
of uh smith's slap yes that [ __ ] hurt
you played ali i can't even play floyd
mayweather it's a good joke so basically
he said f your
hostage video rock again referred to
will smith
shook smith and reverence former death
row records all right
that's pretty he also said something i
thought was really interesting he said
for 30 years you were proc you you you
played uh a perfect person oh dave
chabelle said i said we've we've seen
the mask like he took the mask off and
was that chappelle though or whatever
else at that time oh i thought you took
the mask off and you're a human like
this yeah for 30 years you've had a
clean record well 30 years you're
playing a perfect person and now you can
be now you can be flawed like this
yeah
he's taking way more [ __ ] than i thought
he would will yeah man in this climate
too
to be honest i i'm surprised i haven't
been worse for him
he's been back on instagram like there
was like a rat or lizard in his thing he
posted but
but he's taking a seat for a little who
i didn't realize is one of the first
people to get completely annihilated and
canceled was roseanne barr i forgot
about it yes she was
remember show was popping it was blowing
up and then she started tweeting because
they were saying that she got really
conspiracy theories and alex jones yep
sorry blast stuff off and then she made
a racial reference on twitter yeah to to
the uh i think the transportation sector
yeah and then people got mad because
they're like dude you've been ruthless
and non-censored in in your apology you
blame it on whatever xanax and then
xanax came out was like one of our side
effects is not being racist
yeah
i don't think she knew that woman was
even black i i yeah
that's the problem because she's been
like unfiltered an entire career and
then when it came to the apology she's
like oh i was on ambi that's not my
fault yeah it's ambient she was like i
was on ambien i didn't know what i was
doing i i thought she was white and her
apology was just like ah that's not good
man so i don't identify as a white woman
i'm a jewish woman
she's a strange bird yeah hilarious i
mean rogan had a denver product yeah
rogan's close with her yep yeah they
talk yep her and russell peters are
super close too and she seems to not
come back to she's you know well they
were saying like her crowd used to be
like female liberals forever with jean
roseanne then when this happened and she
jumped on that q and on train so she was
like far right now so she has a fan base
and does her thing she's on something
like one of those far right networks
rumble or something no i don't know i
don't call it rumble but i forget who
exactly she's on but uh she does a lot
of that stuff now because then that the
like the real trumpers and stuff all
support her now so she still has a fan
base just complete 180 what she had to
probably make
i don't know about that but yeah
roseanne was massive
massive
uh speaking of trump so he said if he
does run for president again he's going
to pardon
yeah he's going to do full pardons for
those people that actually did the right
on january 6th hmm
i don't know if that's the man i mean
well he uh i will tell i will look very
favorable about full pardons if i
decided to run and if i win
we had a very reliable source tell us
that him and desantis are running
i've heard that very reliable yes source
i believe
yeah
well that would be
the best thing for desantis in many ways
it's a great way to set himself up for
you know
i wonder if desantis wants to be
associated because trump's so polarized
and so
unprofessional as a president and
desantis is professional a lot of people
yeah a lot of his the people that he has
endorsed have not
done so well
right
and like dr oz like um
well uh
herschel walker i mean yeah no i know
they haven't been the best they haven't
been the best
[ __ ] but desantis has a track record
like if trump co-signs him it's game on
yeah he's different
churchill walker doctor osborne i mean
yeah
anybody here's this two planes nearly
collide whoa
oh dude they have their video of this
[ __ ]
in midair
yes
take a look at this near-miss video
filmed from inside a single engine
cessna looking down at a delta 757
taking off nearby the cessna's pilot
malik clark took evasive action avoiding
a disaster i knew that this didn't look
right
so immediately i turned right and
i
climbed as deeply as i could because i
didn't look that close right
yeah i mean we're going around you see
it again it's close for the most for it
happened orlando international airport
last month
within 500 feet they said
departure
let me be scared if you're on the plane
nearby and says he was instructed to
overfly the runway where the delta
flight was taking off
both pilots saw each other
pro charger and uh
what heaven did they give you
so you're nothing close i think it's
like you like
you know it's like pretty far away but
still closer than you'd like closer here
here's what's funny about that
you know in a way we still
do live in a racist society
because
when i saw that the pilot was black
i think everybody in the room was
surprised in other words
no but you picture a white guy who's a
pilot for whatever reason but not just
black the way he looks okay oh yeah if
you have like exactly yeah
he's young
when i picture a pilot i picture an old
white guy with a right hand just biased
it's a subconscious it's an older black
guy when in a pilot but that's what
that's what they mean by subconscious
bias that's what they talk about being
like but like
i make fun of it but like that's a
classic example of where i have my own
liability right that's this black guy
who said to me he goes you what uh what
um he goes i'm a doctor when i walk in
the room what i have to deal with is
people's assumptions i gotta i gotta
overcome a bunch of assumptions like
that surprise they go oh you're a doctor
or you're black it's just the way he's
stressing oh he looks young
with this it's like he's a he looks
young he's not dressed as my am i more
alone i'm saying it's interesting that
we that but i don't i'm sure it's like
not racist and my thing i wasn't
surprised because he's black my thing i
was surprised a the way he's dressed not
just like a pilot typically is right and
i assume this is right after so a he's
dressed pretty casually b very young
they could be chinese indian native
american full-blown i mean cherokee
picture older and if they're if they're
young
i'm like
probably not the best pilot if somebody
says the pilot was in my mind the pilot
because i that's all i've seen growing
up was a old white guy with gray hair
i guess that you know that's what you
that's maybe from movies that's just
what's been ingrained in your head all
the time and the world is changing well
no but that yeah but you know when i
hear a woman in the cockpit yeah i get
off the plane i'm sorry where were you
going with it oh my god i'm no no no no
no no i didn't mean that no i don't get
off the plane
no i don't get it you said it no no i
don't mean that i say oh my god we're
living i just came out naturally
we have a woman pilot more power to him
you [ __ ] misogynist i see you oh i
see what you're doing here i see what
you're doing hey hey anyways i see what
you're doing i see what you're doing
this is the more power to her she
deserves it i don't give a [ __ ] just
give me the best pilot man transgender
thank you have a big angry dick
purple hair
if you eat people sometimes yeah i don't
know oh good i want the best yeah it is
strange
but it's like when i see uh the flight
attendants i see a dude
automatically i assume he likes wieners
yeah
um there's not too many straight ones
yep right like if you see a male
dude working a whim salon don't you
assume
probably it's the way weiners taste
just from just just there's just that's
what navigates today i don't know that
they're doing it because they like the
way weiner's taste because that would be
a cannibal who likes to eat genitals
yeah yeah i mean sucking them
i guess maybe i i mean i have to i don't
have to go so black and white with you
have you ever pictured
uh what it's like to suck a dong no no
no no that was a really no no dude that
was a really good you said no seven
times eight times no no
no no no that's a long no i mean
sometimes when youporn recommends stuff
i'm like really i wonder what gave you
that idea but then i'm like something
dude this algorithm is insane something
salgram clearly thinks i'm gay no but
never i would never think never never
watch two guys
this is interesting this bums me out
because tiffany haddish is a good person
and i stand by her and i do oh
she's not that kind of person
we don't know the facts well here's my
thing i agree but perform with tiffany
nice person always been nice to me
gorgeous
whatever and uh i made a joke that
bombed in front of her when they paid me
i'm like come
she took the money never get back that's
fine but um
she i don't know what's going on here i
do know the bit the the skit they did is
awful yeah and when i was in austin i
was looking for sets and like yeah you
can do it at uh cap cities i'm like okay
i'll come friday saturday night when i
get down on the show who's the headliner
like uh ahri uh ari's uh spears
probably gonna wait bright and wait a
little bit let's see how this
how this thing uh smoke and real quick
for the audio listeners it says the
articles tiffany haddish addresses
molestation allegations i know people
have questions i guess there's
molestation and groupings
awful that's all that's an awful uh
thing to post so so this is what is my
problem with it what's awful to post
that article this is yeah that's her
statement no that there's that they're
putting molestation of a child in there
here's what i'm saying they shot it they
shot they shot a sketch for funny or die
it was in poor taste it was a myth it
was called it was called from the uh
from the perspective of a pedophile okay
so it was a big miss it was a different
time when people were way less sensitive
and weight gave comedians a lot more
latitude a lot more
uh i know both these people b you're me
you're missing a one i just think
you're missing a complete
you're so far off buddy and this is why
i wanted you to be careful saying you
support her okay again i support her too
until i get the facts now if what these
people are showing them for which isn't
for the for the sketch b they're showing
them because they're saying tiffany hash
molested that young boy when he was
eight years old that's why there's a
lawsuit
within the sketch no no no no no that's
that's not a lawsuit off ear the boy
said he was molested that's the lawsuit
be i did not yes yeah so before you you
know what i'm saying i'm gonna i'm gonna
have all the time with hold judgment on
all this there you go but i'm gonna say
this i i know tiffany and i know aries
and you know i'm for me i'm going to
give him the benefit of doubt so the
comedians are being sued by siblings
identified jane doe now 22 and john doe
14. jane who is also john's legal
guardians the plaintiff in the lawsuit
both individually and on her brother's
behalf as he is a minor the lawsuit uh
the lawsuit the siblings mother alleges
she and haddish met through county and
developed a close relationship over
their respective divorces all right keep
going
you going after this all right okay
um in the summer of 2013 hattie made a
guest appearance uh at the summer camp
jane was attendant allegedly told her
that she discovered a perfect role for
the teen in a commercial uh they didn't
know anything about the shoot details
the shoot allegedly involved haddish
teaching jane how to mimic sucking
weiner for a skit about kids arguing
over sub sandwich all right um
keep going
that's her thing just saying you know i
know you have a lot of questions i can't
speak on it
the lawsuit claims before sender home a
year later allegedly reached out again
to express interest in john for a
nickelodeon sizzle reel suit claims a
seven-year-old was molested this is
where it gets dicey the suit claims that
the seven-year-old was molested by hash
and spares while feminine
yeah so in other words
so that this is what i thought it wasn't
uh it was an offset and that's very
important distinction she's being it was
the sketch itself
that went too far okay that they shot
and what i'm trying to say is that i
think that this was a major clumsy miss
obviously in poor taste obviously if
they could do it again they would take
it back
it was just a big [ __ ] here's
something else you guys should know
to defend tiffany and uh ari spares
is apparently the family of these kids
have been trying to do this for years
asking for money and to settle
so apparently they've been coming for
years now just
especially in the climate where it's
come to light yes and you know the
police take something really seriously
they couldn't find an attorney to pick
up the case because they're like you
have no grounds at all so every attorney
was initially taking on a case there
were several ultimately dropped the
matter once it became clear the claims
were meritless and miss haddish would
not be uh not be shaken down because let
me tell you something this is on film
the nypd
and and detectives look at these things
very closely so it's very important they
deemed this not a a
uh a case where you could prosecute or
put somebody in jail
this is a civil case this is brought by
the parents yeah it's dicey it's dicey i
tiffany haddish i've known her since she
was 18 years old and i know this for a
fact that girl's done more to help
people
who need it and who she probably
shouldn't even help she's done more to
help people than a lot of people i know
she's a [ __ ]
good person
i don't believe that aries spears has
ever molested a child just i just don't
there's no evidence for that yeah i i
don't know i don't know tiffany but what
i do know is if you let's say you are a
pedophile which tiffany sure is [ __ ]
and either you are not no
but i'm just saying tiffany i need to be
on a little more than aries but with
tiffany if you are a pedophile trust me
there would be more than one it's not
something you try once of course so
there's not her nature no right she's a
good person no and also they've been
trying to do this for years the only
thing where it's dicey is
you'd have to look at the contract the
kids signed with funny or die because
they're saying it's caused like trauma
through the years that they're 22 year
olds so they might be able to sue on
that case for the definition for all
that stuff this was i don't know i
didn't see the sketch but i heard it was
pretty like oof right and i get it you
see it mark yeah it was like i'm sure it
was very cringy thank you very cringey
right i i get taken some swings what i'm
saying is that that was a major miss but
that doesn't make tiffany haddish or
airy spears pedophiles at all and it
doesn't make them child molesters agree
it was a fuck-up and that's what it
makes them and i think i think you
should defend tiffany and aries until
you have better evidence from that
that's that's where i stand yes i'm with
you on that yeah
there's one that i just sent you but
could there be anything worse when
you're just tied to that [ __ ] [ __ ] man
my god battlefield what no it's it's i
mean it's games that match like if
there's even a little bit of smoke
you're [ __ ] oh tate reacts to us
hold up
who is true geordi on instagram he'll
even publicly talk about it so let's uh
he'd love your company hit that guy up
you know i'm sure you two would make a
great couple he'd love your company and
then joe rogan was talking about us and
uh again making very very valid points
about the censorship and the [ __ ]
garbage that's going on in the world
today and how this eventually has to
stop
for me
shout out to joe rogan
yeah so i'm really really glad that the
other people on the show uh let joe know
that it was completely consensual
because that's the thing i understand if
something's taken by other people you
mean brenda he's gonna give him a shout
out i don't know i've been there
that's why they tried to silence me
because i was fixing all of the
narratives and kind of paint about me so
they tried to silence me but they failed
but i think joe and i at some point in
the future gonna have a nice long
conversation i have a feeling it's gonna
be a very very interesting time i look
forward to it uh it's probably the only
thing i'd bother traveling to america
for so i look forward to getting in
touch with joe again we were talking on
instagram before my instagram got taken
down but i have other routes to get
through to him and talk to joe so i'm
really excited to get in touch with him
once again and there's been a whole
bunch of other people who stuck up for
us
good
yeah
good gave you that shout out there you
go baby
and i thought it was also an interesting
discussion in and of itself on the on
the podcast when you guys brought them
up yep
yep yep kids
so that's cool i guess brandon we did it
again we did it [ __ ]
guys do we have any more no you want
more i'm always down for more give us
two more i like chaos in the dojo
climber falls and dies
argentinian uh
vice president assassination attack yeah
somebody tried to shoot at him and
at her so you'll see
check out the gun that comes out at the
very end right
here where
economists fired drop the gun
and they beat the shot
and now thanks
oh [ __ ]
imagine how awful that would it'd be
game set match
and his gun just [ __ ] it jammed
it's loaded with five bullets holy [ __ ]
well that's security not great
if you just walk up and shoot in the
face a security yeah what are we doing
it's like that uh was it the japanese
prime minister right the guy had a
homemade guy abe just shot walked up and
shot him yeah
dq ice cream machine has maggots in it
still those this is great
those blizzards are very helpful these
blizzards are lit well just that one has
it he could see you take a video where
it was a chocolate covered maggot for
the worst for me he said the name for
the world is for me they're trying to
get him to stop videoing him
get these maggots
right there
that's high protein ice cream yeah a
little worms in your blizzard you have a
protein ice cream bro when's that saying
i had a blizzard i haven't dude i was
trying to tell my kids how good
blizzards are i haven't had one since i
was a kid i'm cute i'm like no because
they like make flurries i'm like no
blizzard's blizzards i drive dude it
takes you an hour to get there it's hot
i pick them up i drive home they're like
what is this because high school's so
much better now dude the the the
mcflurry from mcdonald's destroyed oh
really oh oh the soft story dude decides
mcdonald's this is the best of all time
really i mean soft serve yeah after
vanilla ice cream probably the best in
cow best but
afters after yeah is it softer no no no
i like soft syrup but this this is soft
oh but mcdonald's soft serve dude
they're mcflurry you know how to make
flavors no oh
it's i mean i want a soft-serve vanilla
ice cream cone from mcdonald's it's hot
out why not did they have a ice cream at
the fair
malibu yeah they did hello my son got it
and it got all over his head oh my
[ __ ] face do my kick out all over his
face listen oh you want me a dad and you
want to take your kids album yeah my kid
my son my bossy loves strawberry ice
cream so he gets it and i want to help
him he's freaking out he wants to do it
himself i'm like okay you do it dude
it's just
a
[ __ ] storm he's wearing a white shirt
just strawberry ice cream down the front
i'm like all right we can't walk and he
goes daddy hates when he's like wait
daddy i'm like we need to find your
shirt we're in this malibu store to give
him a shirt
do you have any like toddler shirt she
goes well we have a few uh shoes you
know what we have this tie-dye one says
malibu uh uh brad pitt wart same one
brad pitt one in my head i'm like that
ain't good for me
ready for this two shirts 115 dollars oh
she rang it up and you know when you're
embarrassed i was like
oh there you go
you got me oh there you go you got me oh
brad pitt west oh yeah yeah yeah i'm
here though no
oh you took a picture in one time okay
my son my son is without a doubt going
to be a comic and if he's not i don't
know what he's going to do because it's
probably the only career path he's just
it's just in him
and there was a in the ride there's a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] giant clown statue and its
finger is doing this it's scary it's
going like that it's pointing like that
gun yep
and my son goes my son in he's in the
front of the line and there's all these
people and he's like whoa oh boy
and he's the he's got his butt he's got
the guys poke me in the butt dad and i
go stop doing that now stop doing that
on the phone yeah stop doing that okay
yeah
and he goes okay okay i'll stop it he
turns around now he's going whoa here we
go and now he's pointing at his dick not
my ball dead yeah my ball just standing
in line yeah and i go fin i'm like i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill your finger look at
the people
die people are looking i'm like hey stop
doing it goes okay whoa again there it
is again
i'm gonna i go i'm literally i'm gonna
kill you and he turns around it's on my
neck again
i'm not doing it dad he's pointing right
on my dick because i'm my fault my
[ __ ]
i lose my [ __ ] mind with that kid he
he knows how to push my buttons and just
well he's a comic yeah i used to do the
same thing to my [ __ ] dad yeah i
remember my dad would go so nuts with me
because i would do whatever i could to
bother him i would he'd be like
what do you want to do young age we're
on vacation i go what do you want to do
now just stand there he's in a bad mood
and he goes what i go what do you want
to do now and he goes
he goes
we're going to wait to go to dinner i go
no but now right now it was just before
after you flew into lax and then i was
going to the camps yeah did he hit you a
lot i like no and i go like this you
want to do this and i just start doing
that did your parents hit you mark
no never maybe like once
like my dad like spanked me a few times
but [ __ ] like my mom took a ride and
cropped tomorrow yeah my parents would
unleash on me but i had a loud voice
would have yell but no like i don't know
i don't have memories no i got i got
wacky i get hit me too yeah not but my
dad but my mom both of them five foot
two italian woman yeah my mom just
punched my brother in the face really oh
yeah my mom wouldn't smash our tvs with
like that hammer oh just punch him oh
yeah he was brutal to me something he
deserved oh yeah because well my dad hit
me once because i hit my sister he goes
what did you do to her this bang
smackdown yeah oh my god oh that's one
thing i i'm pretty i'm pretty big push
over the kids even when i yell and i'm
bigger than they don't give a [ __ ] but
if
one like if tiger hits boss or so that's
the one time they know my dad didn't
stand for me hitting my sister that's
not happening i remember my brother beat
me up in front of my grandpa and he's in
world war ii he's like you know if i'm
[ __ ] sick he's like you think i
risked my life on the battlefield
killing nazis so you two could do this
even me and my brother that's when we
teamed up like jesus christ pt like that
[ __ ] yeah ptsd you guys used to
go playing checkers did you guys go out
there there's nothing to do with nazis
oh yeah but you were a little [ __ ] did
you cry a lot when he did all that
nonsense
right nonstop yeah oh terrifying no no
no there's like bro you weren't fighting
back no well i'm like one in three
thousand but the one was really good but
did you but did you
we had to go to anger management he got
so bad but yeah he had a good anger man
so you got the [ __ ] kicked out non-stop
i was terrified of my house yeah yeah
that's where am i trying wait wait so so
yeah so you didn't but you never [ __ ]
but it made you tough didn't it yeah
shortly yes yeah but but did you did you
fight backwards you just get you just
kick you i try to fight back he's bigger
than me i didn't get back to like
sophomore year and then when was when
was the equalizing event
there never was one my entire
child went back one time just one time
what happened whipped his ass maybe he's
just having an off date i'm sleeping
i won were you guys would you close
fists right mark's oh dude
no this isn't that rich fighting you did
dude jay would take like bats and clubs
jay would like bash my head in the
bricks dude yeah wwf style man what
would be yeah i was scaring my lip from
him he took my head and bashed in the
brick wall what would be the the
catalyst to it
oh name something brian because he had
anger issues because my parents got
divorced so i have drama yeah so i have
all this drama yeah yeah yeah what else
you want to talk about man
oh i don't know i'd beat him at nba jam
okay oh i would i would pretend he would
beat me all the time so i didn't have to
get my ass up i'm like man you're
getting really good meanwhile i could
probably beat him nine times out of ten
so you just oh i would lie about you you
were abused oh yeah yeah horrible beasts
yeah i would lie about the we were into
nba and nfl cards and like mlb i don't
put my pack and i knew he'd whip my ass
if i got better cards than him so i'm
like nothing well i got some fire cards
but if you beat him he would kick your
[ __ ] yeah i'd let him win oh yeah
really and if you got an argument i
don't mean like a puncher i mean like a
beatdown you'd get you'd get you could
be worked up you're getting marked up
marked up oh bloody lip teeth and your
mom was kicked in the face
and mom would lose her [ __ ] no no no
no my mom would do nothing brian yeah so
i have mom issues yeah
yeah man you got mom issues too yeah
yeah she did nothing to stop your your
own home had no sanctuary no no no very
broken yes
that's like a guy my dad's friend used
to go to bed with his shoes on because
his dad would come home drunk
and just one some days would be like i'm
going to beat you up
yeah he'd have his shoes and his clothes
on just so he had to run out the window
that's a great way to grow up [ __ ]
alcohol that's great yeah absolutely i
used to fight grown men in steel cage
and now i do stamp comedy because i grew
up normal
you know what i've yet to meet a comic
or a fighter who had a normal upbringing
i really have
you know i'll fight you right now and
how when did the beatings stop
when did the brother when did the
brother terrorists moved out of the
house when you moved out of the house
yeah when you were so you when you were
16 were you guys still going at it
sometimes i just saw his girlfriend i
pissed in her lip gloss and i ran out of
the house and you got the [ __ ] kicked
out of you
when you came back he just came at you i
said how's that piss taste
funny funny
funny i got beat up for it beginning
comedy beginning comedy beginning comedy
sketch comedy pissing girlfriend's lip
gloss at the time
black girl she didn't appreciate it
either so they double teamed me they
double teamed yeah and the la but but
when you were 14 things were hard
10 11 12 nightmare 13 14 night man
nightmare because that that's yeah
you're you're wide awake i mean you're
you're
you know everything that's going on
pretty well and he was how many years
older two okay so you got 16 versus 14.
not no shot not fun and and now you have
15 versus 13. i mean that's you got to
get the [ __ ] kicked out of you then
nothing else to do he's had a tough day
at school mom and dad are divorced maybe
maybe the kids may phone because braces
and glasses get on your little bro oh
and if you say anything he's gonna [ __ ]
you up
or maybe he just comes in and goes stay
to my room was he a bit sadistic would
he be like why are you looking at me
like that 100 okay say whatever it is
just whatever i ate all the icing on the
strudels the toaster strudels because
i'm fat okay you beat me up for that
because you couldn't stop it well worth
it oh you got a dictionary i would do it
to this day
to this day i put four icings on my
toaster
say you know what [ __ ] you and i text it
to him it takes a picture he'll [ __ ] you
all right
all right okay yeah
but you guys are close now we are yep
still getting some heavy arguments we'll
argue won't fight each other though but
you'll get into that same enemies little
bro learned to train yeah you have the
same energy little bro learn to train
yeah little bro grew up to be big bro
yeah but little bro as a kid it was like
comes out for snake diaz every day
it was a nightmare
what else you got jen is that it you
wanna see the last one that mark had the
dojo one yeah
okay this is my favorite [ __ ] i bet jay
attacks you oh it wasn't that bad yeah
for you i know
what are they training for world star
yeah it was just a slap but
oh
oh it's one verse
oh i don't know what's going on oh he
has to get beat up
oh oh my god
oh it's an initiation oh it's an
initiative no they all go
i don't think so brian they're all black
belts what are you initiating
well it's not very good fighting
see they all take turns
well you gotta learn how to fight back
dude you're not fighting back you can't
jump
oh that kick
i don't know what kind of dojo this is
that's awesome that was weird yeah
someone tried the people's elbow at the
end on them
all right well i'm not going to go to
that school because i don't want to
learn how to fight
that was terrible he's a black belt and
he was hitting him with his hands like
that let me see that technique again
that's that's absolutely appalling hey
brian hey hold on position look yeah
yeah yeah sure closet
least of their concerns right huh that
would be the least of their concerns
yeah hand slapping yeah the dojo is you
you you gang up on the end beat them up
yeah yeah the open hand palm slap
it sounds like an initiation to get the
next level of belt oh no no i don't
think so i think this is a competition
and it's insane with a stick too
and somebody has a stick kicked all
right now they stopped that's just weird
who knows what's going on and they're
also on cement but there's just a tarp
put down right
hand slapping is not what i'm worried
about it's not great
you know it says jiu-jitsu yeah you
gotta you gotta have eyes on the back of
your head dude you gotta have eyes on
the back of your head
all right he's not getting his head
kicked in oh that was weird the guy
tried the people's elbow yeah he missed
and she landed on concrete that looks
like it hurt
yeah i was working well i'm not signing
up for that uh well yeah i was beat up
as a child um please don't beat me up in
appleton wisconsin this thursday friday
saturday appleton come get some and then
ontario california ontario improvs next
week thursday friday saturday my
favorite clubs hopefully it gets less
hot boston is in three weeks september
29th through october 1st laugh boston
that's almost sold out one show thursday
two friday two saturday get you some san
jose and salt lake city just got out in
october end of october i'm in calgary
canada
get your tickets at thickboy.com we have
a uh labor day sale going on right now
as well chin i want you to include the
trailer hit it right now man tears yeah
do it right now if you want i always
thought the rule was you had to cover
your face
when a man cries unless you're on
horseback looking over your conquered
lands
the world would be a lot different if
men could cry
one of my best friends called me and he
goes
what's going on well
i'm sad
he was like well you got the wrong
number
when men meet each other only thing
going on in each man's mind is
can i kill this [ __ ]
so my girl wanted me to run an errand
and she goes take my bike but it has a
basket on the front of it and i was like
i'm going to walk
with the kids she goes don't be
ridiculous and i was like unless you
have a cobra for that basket
[Music]
i'm not i hate this mantra of course you
can cry if your cat died and you cry of
course cry i'm not going to be mean to
you in the moment but i'm never going
into business with you
all right then your dates raleigh north
carolina good night september 8th and
9th and 10th san jose california the
weekend after that september 15 16 17.
specan washington spokane comedy eclipse
number 22 to the 24th brian.com
and uh man tears
my my special is
on youtube right now come get some comes
with a free uh ball of tears comes with
a free bottle of my tears
your cell and tears selling tears tears
for food call
good call
would have been a good little thing to
sell us our tears yeah we'll just do it
as water yep be funny too late now look
a little like 10 minutes
all right that's it this is fine kid
we're out